each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
welcome to the session data shooting we
have I'm here early and we have three
talks in this session and all pertaining
to the question of how long ranges that
confusing for you sign so our first
speaker is Randy Brian 15 computer
science or cognitive Ellen and he's
thought actually quite deeply the
question of the architecture computing
three signs so I'm ready I kind of gave
myself a dope swept this morning for
coming up with the title applying Google
style computing to east science at a
workshop sponsored by Microsoft but
there's actually a reason to that it's
not just a random attribution so of
course a lot of e science is all about
big data very large data sources and not
just in scale but with the desire to do
a lot of sophisticated computation over
it and of course that's in science yeah
but also in the business world in the
medical world and all over and so
there's many different fields that are
really interested in in fact the search
domain of web search has really been a
big driver for this so when I say Google
style I mean a couple I do I Tony I ice
Tony I said that I gave myself a dope
slap this morning though so but I mean
two things one is a style of building
computer systems on a scale that sort of
unprecedented of course we don't really
honestly expect to build computer
systems this scale for our rather
poultry science problems but still it
the idea of assembling very very large
systems out of essentially commodity
parts and
so in fact Google used to be very
secretive about it but recently you can
get youtube videos of tours of the
inside of their data centers so they
build them in a modular way I think
Microsoft does this now two of just
filling up a shipping containers full of
of machines and then piling them into
big warehouses plumbing them with a lot
of electricity and a lot of cold water
and letting them run cook together by
relatively low performance communication
compared to say what you'd build in a
really large super computing system so
these things are engineered very
carefully but yet they're also
engineered to be very price of
perfective and one attribute of that is
that they break all the time every
component fails all the time and the
systems are then engineered using
software based fault tolerance to be
able to continue running in the face of
repeated component failures the other
thing is is the MapReduce programming
model or the idea that rather than being
down at the suit of bare metal writing
code that you're up at a higher level
thinking in a sort of data parallel way
about what operations you want to
perform on the data without so much
concern of where is that data located
how do i schedule the tasks what do I do
when one of the files disappears because
the disk fails and so that's what i mean
by google style is a style of building
computer systems and a style of
programming them so I this is a area
that I've been very interested in for
several years so let me talk some about
the general properties and principles of
it of course we know the driving factor
behind why there's so much data out
there at least one of the reasons is the
tremendous progress in magnetic storage
technology so that you can go off and
buy a multi terabyte disk drives for
less than ten cents per gigabyte and in
fact it over the years I've given this
talk I have
to keep going back to Amazon to get the
latest price on a disk drive because it
keeps dropping the so that's a good news
is that the data storage is essentially
free in terms of just the raw capacity
the bad news is that the transfer rate
of getting information on and off of
disks or getting it across even a local
area network is a much bigger problem so
a terabyte is nothing in terms of buying
a disk drive to store it but if you just
want to copy or even read through all
the data on a disk drive it takes
several hours and if you want to copy it
from one machine to another or even
worse from one end of the country to the
other you're talking hours days possibly
to do the transfer so what it means is
that you can build up these very large
data sets but then they kind of get
stuck in one place and even if you want
to then in one computation do something
that will access say terabytes worth of
data it's actually a fairly challenging
task so for example imagine something
you want to do where you have a terabyte
size data set and you just want to scan
through and do some very rudimentary
task find some label in there compute
the average of a group of numbers well
the only way you're going to be able to
do that in a reasonable amount of time
is to distribute that date over many
disk drives have all them working with
their own processors working locally and
then communicating over some decent but
not necessarily a super duper local area
internet and so that's why you moved to
these systems that have shipping
containers full of processors and disks
working together and why that what the
motivation behind that style of system
building so we call these a data
intensive supercomputer or data
intensive scalable computer it's mostly
an acronym and look search of a name but
the idea of it is again to focus on a
very large scale computer systems but
the real purpose in life is to be able
to work with very well
large scale data and do interesting
computation over that data not just
store and retrieve it but be able to
apply various analytic tasks to it so my
suit of four characteristics of that is
a the main issue is the sort of the
moniker would be terabytes not teraflops
that it's really about how much storage
you can maintain and make good use of
the other is a programming model where
you're not thinking about the machine as
much as the problems that you're trying
to solve an ability to interact with it
directly rather than say a traditional
supercomputer where it's a very bachelor
did processing and then finally from a
system perspective having a system
that's engineered so that you can
withstand the continuous failures that
would happen at the hardware level and
possibly the software level and not have
to bring down the whole machine so just
as a to go through some of those
attributes in a little more detail the
idea of in a most large scale computing
systems it's somebody else's problem
where the data is going to be held and
how to get it into the system in order
to do the computation but with these
scale data sets were dealing with that's
really not feasible to move it into the
system and so this was one of Jim grace
things it's easier to move the code to
the data than the data to the code so
what you'd really like to do is have
this data all collected and held
together and managed with all the right
stuff and continuously updated and and
handled but then when you want to do
some analytic task you then ship a
program over to this system run it on
there might be fairly sophisticated what
you're trying to do with it but really
do the computation on site as I
mentioned the idea of having a
programming model that is not directly
up thinking about the the raw hardware
which is the way most programming of say
based on MPI is done where you really
think about I've got 64 processors I
need to partition my simulation domain
into 64 regions and run them each and
parallel on these different
processors but rather you think about
I've got a bunch of data there in a
bunch of files I want to collectively do
some computation over all of that data
and then there's a runtime system that
deals with issues about how to manage
the tasks how to distribute the data how
to locate things how to deal with
failures as I mentioned this reliability
is sort of key to being able to scale a
system up to a really large size and not
have it cost hundreds of millions of
dollars just to build one system like
you'd see in a supercomputer so for
being able to use this there is a
growing body of open-source software of
the project called Hadoop which is
largely been supported by yahoo in fact
is available and it provides a basic
parallel file system and a MapReduce
programming framework and so there's
increasing interest in Hadoop and a
large community of people using it these
days so let's focus on one particular
area of e science where we have some
experience and that's in dealing with
astronomy and so in astronomy there's
sort of two main types of data one is
sky surveys which is of course what Jim
Gray got started with Alex and starting
with the Sloan survey I believe where
there's just huge amounts of
astronomical data being collected and uh
and Jim really demonstrated that this
brings in a whole new possibility of
computer scientists working with domain
scientists to make this data available
and do interesting things with it
another end of it is the data that comes
out of supercomputers they spew out tons
and tons of data and so in particular
here at Carnegie Mellon we have a
cosmology center of called the
McWilliams center that runs very large
simulations in the evolution of the
universe and then
after that they've got a lot of data
generated that they want to analyze and
and see what's going on so we've started
a project that we call astro disk and it
involves a few people julio lopez who's
back there eugene fink and graduate
student binh phu where we're using some
of this astronomy data as a driver for
exploring some of these more of the
computer science issues behind this data
intensive computing so in particular
using the Hadoop framework to do the
types of computational tasks that
astronomers want to be able to do to
their data and how do sort of scientific
algorithms then of scale up and I'll fit
within a MapReduce framework and also
some interest in the more persistent
storage in addition to do providing a
programming framework there's an
increasing interest in what we'll call
scalable tables so a scalable table is
sort of layering some aspects of
database functionality on top of a
parallel file system so it's not a true
database you can't do arbitrary
relational queries but it provides some
of the key attributes that people
associate with databases that the data
are organized in schemas through some
structure to it through simple queries
where you can access individual parts of
it and some amounts of transaction and
Adam icity in how you do the updating
without while sort of always thinking
about what can be done on a very large
scale using a distributed
fault-tolerance file system and
therefore backing off from some of the
full-fledged attributes of relational
databases we've been gotten funding that
allows us to do this work and also to
build our own cluster not a huge cluster
but a big enough one that we've been
developing so this has been funded by
Google partly and the more foundation
we've been working somewhat
with people at University of Washington
as well so just as an example of one of
the projects that we've worked on the
work known as halo finding is you given
a bunch of particles may be stars each
of which has its own a position in XYZ
space and it has some identifier
associated with it and now what we're
trying to do is merge these into regions
are based on some radius of what's
considered nearby and then each particle
then gets assigned an ID identifying
which region it's part of so this is a
course a kind for which there's been a
lot of work but how can we do this using
MapReduce so in the particular
implementation it's sort of what you'd
expect that you start with just the raw
data which is a files of the individual
objects labeled with their XYZ
coordinates and then there you use a map
to then distribute those into regions so
you partition all of space into a set of
overlapping regions and then map each
particle into one or more regions in
which it's located and so that's done
using map one MapReduce step and then we
have these regions who now we can
locally in a sort of massively parallel
way just apply a region finding or halo
finding to those using the so-called
friends of friends algorithm that just
sort of greedily clusters things
together and so for each of those
regions are using just the normal
sequential code for that we identify
those and then we now have a bunch of
regions each of which has labeled halos
and now what we have to do is some
amount of coalescing of the the halos
that split across multiple regions but
there's a few enough of those in the
simple enough task that we can just do
that using a single union-find running
on a sequential machine so we've
successfully implemented this and
applied it to some fairly large scale
data sets and it's been a demonstration
that at least this type of task is
fairly suitable for a MapReduce
computing framework so just to finish up
then the sort of idea we've been looking
at then is its idea of a very large
scale data intensive computing and in
fact it's interesting this morning of
course the discussion a lot of it was
building on Jim Gray's legacy but I
think one of the parts that Jim Gray
unfortunately hasn't been able to
partake in is this idea that it's not
just the data that we want to get but we
also want to do computation that is
distributed and spread over these very
large data sets and so we need to go
beyond sort of a traditional database
view of the world to one where we're
merging on top of the data storage
issues is how do we then map very
large-scale distributed computing onto
that data and that's where we're taking
this particular project and I think it
will have a lot of importance in the
domain of e science so thank you yes
and
I think the mainly is a bigger the open
source implementations of these tables
are still only now getting to be good
enough to be serious contenders for real
science be using they're pretty crafty
up to
well wait a second MapReduce is joined
the basic MapReduce operations and will
sort everything and stick it together
not not exact I mean it's a type of this
restricted know you can express any type
of noise paper is that basically you can
express any database confrontation you
can express not efficient but the point
is you can there is no such thing as a
deficient relational database over
billions options okay I'm not going to
argue for the birth of the vertical
people will argue and the vertical
people are being careful any other
questions that's good that's fun